se ha sentado aquí demasiado tiempo para
lo que ha terminado haciendo en nombre
de dios bayas
caos en la cámara de los comunes el
primer ministro boris johnson se
enfrentó a una incómoda sesión de
control este miércoles mientras la
presión continuó aumentando por las
fiestas en downing street en plena
pandemia durante la sesión
parlamentarios de todo el país
compartieron las historias de ciudadanos
que sufrieron durante el confinamiento
criticaron a johnson por creer que está
por encima de las normas y lo llamaron
una desgracia el año pasado su majestad
estaba sola en el funeral del hombre con
el que estuvo casada durante 73 años en
la vigilia de ese funeral se llenó una
maleta con alcohol y se llevó a downing
street donde tocó un dj y el personal
festejo hasta tarde and light and drive
teniendo en cuenta que el primer
ministro viktor las normas porque creen
que esta nueva defensa va a funcionar es
que la uaq aumenta las posibilidades de
que johnson se enfrente a una moción de
censura dado que la propia bancada
conservadora se ha puesto en su contra
incluso el diputado conservador
christian whiteford se pasó al partido
laborista momentos antes de la sesión
decenas de representantes del partido de
johnson reconocieron haber mandado
cartas la moción de confianza después de
que el premier afirmara que nadie le
alertó que las fiestas en downing street
iban en contra de las normas
absolutamente claros el honorable
caballero sigue haciendo preguntas que
sabe que serán abordadas en su totalidad
por la investigación está perdiendo el
tiempo de la cámara y el tiempo de la
gente
y el número de parlamentarios pidiendo
someter a johnson a una moción de
confianza es secreto pero distintos
representantes aseguran que el umbral de
54 puede alcanzarse muy pronto